il fait trop froid les êtres humains
sont ce qu'ils ont toujours aidé et il
ne change pas je dois protéger à il est
maintenant le meilleur moyen de la
protéger et de construire un monde
meilleur où elle pourra vivre maintenant
si je reste ici dans six mois tu seras
moins si tu perds tu trouvera peut-être
un monde
ou tu pourra changer les choses
[Musique]
manille
vous avez tué mais sonne pourquoi je
viens juste d'arriver ce n'est pas moi
vous voulez y ont passé un génocide pour
un problème technique de votre vaisseau
saturn 5 devrait être accessible à tout
le monde m'a dit non dites moi ce qui se
passe ici rien ne change si on ne fait
pas un petit sacrifice c'est le feu
qu'il avait été voté dites moi comment
pourquoi vous faites ça vous cet
intérieur
je ne fais rien il n'y aura plus tôt
station oil et la caisse dans la réserve
du vaisseau c'est une porte à faux
[Musique]
espace riz kouassi derrien découvrait
que votre gouvernement veut tuer des
réfugiés récemment c'est magnifique
je me demande ce qu'on va trouver en
arrivant
[Musique]
et
découverts
[Musique]
et quand tu seras pas revenue
tu auras donner encore plus de sens est
d'importance à la vie de tous ceux qui
ont fait de toi l'homme que tu es
[Musique]